hi so this video not really sure what
its gonna be I have recently been
struggling with inspiration and
sometimes you guys ask me hey how do I
become inspired to do anything to make
art to make videos to do this to do that
I don't really have an answer for you
but when I'm struggling with inspiration
to do things I actually remember this
while i was on the book tour i used to
do a lot of graphic design and it'd be
hard because clients would have these
crazy ideas and these these
misconceptions of things that they
thought they wanted where i'm like i
don't think that's what you have in mind
what you're telling me so Ivan go to the
bookstore and I would sit on the floor
and suppose the barnes and nobles and
they hang borders back in the days what
i used to go to quite often and i would
still in the floor and i would go
through design books typography books
photography books and just sort of try
to get ideas for things and just to see
work that other people have created and
I'm just like wow and it would just
inspire me because I'd be fascinated by
the things that people could create by
the world around us in which people
would go to travel to get amazing
photographs and this is before i had
ever traveled before i had ever gone
anywhere ever done really anything
except sit in my house and make stuff on
my computer for other people so for me
that was always how i got my inspiration
but currently I'm sort of at an
inspiration loss I guess I feel like a
lot of stuff that people are posting on
YouTube it's also sort of like the
challenge videos and like the ask videos
and that's the stuff that I also post on
YouTube but I want to do something else
but i'm not sure what I want to do I
miss doing music videos I miss doing so
many other things that I used to make
that it's hard because with the whole
book tour and then working on a movie
and doing all of the
vid cons and comic cons that doesn't
leave time to make my to make my little
videos here on the YouTube so I'm trying
to figure out how to balance doing all
this other stuff but yet doing what I
really like is making videos here I have
worked on so many shows and stuff for
everybody else and then when you go to
my channel it's like cool we're a little
of stuff you did Michael it's not here
it's for everybody else so I guess my
question is what do you guys want to
watch what do you want to see what is
your most I don't know one thing that
you guys like to watch on youtube I love
doing the cooking videos so that's
definitely something that I'm going to
continue to do I love doing the tech
Tuesday I did an interview today
actually and the reporter asked me where
I get my inspiration and it kind of made
me stop and think and I didn't really
say anything for a couple of seconds I
was like actually I get my inspiration
from my viewers they inspire me to not
only be a better person but they
inspired me to create content I read
their comments and I see the things that
they like and then I try to figure out
how I can make fun stuff for them but
it's also so important that if you guys
are making YouTube videos that you're
making this content for you because if
you're not having fun doing it it's
gonna be very obvious like this video I
kind of just sat down I hope it's even
working because I got a new camera and I
kind of new microphone as well so I'm
just kind of figuring it out so I
thought this was gonna be kind of a fun
little test video and see what happens
so my whole thought process was I'm
gonna sit down and just talk just talk
so I hope it actually is even working
because I was gonna test it out but I
didn't so hopeful this is even working I
don't know uh VidCon is coming up next
weekend and VidCon always actually
inspires me and it's getting just see
the other people that are creating
videos what is also getting to see you
guys like I don't think you guys
understand how you keep us motivated and
not just by comments but like actually
getting to see you guys at events it's
so freaking awesome to see how much I
don't know like how much we impact your
lives and and how you know I don't know
I just I love it I love hearing your
stories I love hearing how you guys have
like found me and just not just me but
like all my YouTube friends too and it's
just such an awesome community I'm just
really freaking excited to see you guys
I had a great time at comic-con so thank
you to all of you guys that came out I
didn't even post my comic con video I
took a couple days a couple weeks
actually I definitely have taken a month
or two off see ya when the hell those
videos looking more sure let me know
what you think let me know how it sounds
there seems to be a lot of echo which is
not good what let me know what you guys
do for inspiration let me know what your
dreams are let me know what your hopes
hopes hopes and dreams hopes and dreams
usually go together but really if you
hope to do something add enough like you
can do it I will never ever forget some
of you guys if you've read it already
then spoiler alert if you haven't I had
this boss who basically told me I
I worthless if I quit working for him I
wasn't gonna become anything I wasn't
gonna do anything nobody was ever gonna
pay me more money than he would ever pay
me because I don't know he was crazy
actually they either way using that
motivation of somebody telling you that
you're gonna be nothing and you're gonna
not do anything with your life I was
like all right cool left his office I
cried for I don't even know how long
like I remember distinctly walking down
back to my office and just like trying
not to cry because I was like this dude
just told me that I was nothing I was
worthless that I'm not gonna make
anything of myself and I was like wool
you're a pig first of all what I really
am trying to say is that you know a lot
of times you're gonna have those kind of
setbacks in life but for me that wasn't
necessarily a setback it was sort of
like okay I'm free I can leave this
place and I know that I can do something
better than what I'm currently doing and
I don't need some crazy person telling
me that I'm worthless because first of
all how is worthless you would not have
hired me you would not have wanted me to
work for you and you would not be so
upset that I was leaving because he
basically was trying to
reverse-psychology me telling me that I
wasn't gonna find a better jobs so that
I would stay there and then finally now
that I'm older I think I'm actually
realizing what he was doing there psycho
psycho female blowing up the phone lines
ticking up tighten that screw it's been
those four locks and a whole of its land
was in bad luck excuse you limp biscuit
um yeah I sure hope this video's you go
to work Oh probably not because my hair
is one microphone back to the future I
think I'm actually gonna back to the
future viewing party then watch them all
back to back because that's something I
never did that is something that I did
do with Star Wars so I made the mistake
of watching them because for some reason
when I was younger I my
whenever we never they never made me
watch Star Wars I don't understand ma
yeah why I don't get it don't get it we
saw everything else but I watched it
starting from not 345 I started one two
three and then four five six weird
strange I'm not sure how I feel about it
I don't think I should have watched it
that way but I don't know that's what I
need to rewatch also there's a lot of
stuff that I need to rewatch that I sort
of feel like I missed out on my
childhood I did a lot of stuff a lot of
things we saw a lot of stuff er there's
a lot of things that I didn't see like I
still don't understand why don't watch
Star Wars when i was younger i asked my
mom and she's like oh I just didn't
think you'd be into it hello what do you
think I'm sitting there playing all my
video games being a little nerd and
you're not gonna show me Star Wars I
know anyway I'm gonna go not really sure
what this video is or what it ended up
turning into but I think you guys are
all fantastic and sometimes you need to
use those little things in life that
might not actually seem like it's a good
thing at the time usually it'll work out
you just gotta use your best judgment so
anyway I'll see you guys at VidCon I
love you and I'll see you later i'm
sweating right now and that's not good
so yeah hope this video worked by